desperate and without documents a woman
from mexico moves to a pension in
cleveland where she begins to have
strange and disturbing visions so today
on cinema recap i'll show you no one
gets out alive
the film begins with a woman who was
talking on the phone saying she does not
want to continue living at the place at
that moment she realizes that there are
strange things happening around her so
she puts the phone down and walks then
she sees an object moving by itself and
when she tries to take steps backwards
she's caught by a strange shadow in the
next scene we see several people in a
vehicle as apparently they are
immigrants who are traveling to the
united states one of these women is
named amber
when she arrives she gets a place to
stay and also a job however after a few
days she's told that she can no longer
stay in that place without an id amber
goes to work where she finds out that
there are rooms available in a house
that is only for women so she asks for a
room there and we see that it is the
same house where the woman from the
beginning of the movie used to live a
man chose her the house which is quite
large so amber decides to stay there the
man tells her that there's another
woman's thing in that place and that in
order to stay there they must pay a
month's brand in advance amber pays and
takes the room then that night when she
was listening to an audio from her
mother she suddenly realizes that there
is a window that connects the floor
below she looks through and realizes
that the other woman who is staying
there is crying however amber ignores
her and tries to go to sleep then she
has some memories of her mother who
lived her last days in the hospital the
next day she goes to work and a friend
of hers tells her that the price for an
id has gone up amber doesn't have money
to pay for it so her friend tells her
that she can take her time to get it she
goes to a dinner with her mother's
cousin who tells her that he can
introduce her to some people who can
offer her a better job but that she must
have an id amber goes home and asks the
owner to give her back the money so she
can pay for an id but he tells her that
he already spent it the next day amber
goes to work and asks her boss to pay
her for a week in advance but he refuses
amber and her friend go out for a drink
and her friend tells her that she can
lend her the money she needs so amber
decides to give her all her savings so
she can buy the id amber goes home and
when she arrives she realizes that there
is a man there trying to enter one of
the rooms she ignores him and goes to
her room later she goes down to the
kitchen and meets two women who are new
there
they have a short talk and then leave at
that moment the owner arrives and amber
tells him about the strange man she saw
before
the owner tells her that that was his
brother
then amber goes to a secret room to see
what's inside she comes across strange
things such as dried up butterflies a
recording of a sacrifice portraits and
books of what appears to be an ancient
ritual at that moment a noise scares her
so she leaves the place quickly and we
see that there's a figure in the
background that was watching her all
along the next day amber goes to work
and realizes that her friend has just
quit she asks her boss to give her the
address of the woman but he ends up
firing her as well amber tries to
contact her friend but she doesn't take
the call so amber realizes that she got
scammed
she goes home worried and takes a shower
when suddenly she hears cries for help
coming from the drain
amber turns scared to the door and sees
a man however when she pulls the curtain
aside he disappears then amber comes out
of the bathroom and talks to the owner
he tells her that he's got some money
that he can return from what she paid in
advance but she has to wait until
tomorrow amber goes to her room and
starts to listen to some audio from her
mother at that moment she sees a ghost
saying her name but it was just a
nightmare then she sees that the door to
her room is open so she approaches to
close it but at that moment she sees a
shadow outside the hall and also hears a
woman wailing amber stands still and
sees how footsteps begin to be marked on
the floor as if someone were entering
her room then she sees another ghost
outside the room which apparently is
going after the ghost that had just
entered amber sees how the two ghosts
begin to fight until they leave the room
then there's silence and amber decides
to go downstairs she sees a lady goes
crying at the end of the hallway and
gets a little closer to see it at that
moment a hand appears and drags the lady
towards the basement amber runs through
her room very scared and begins to
collect all her things to leave
then she calls her mother's cousin to
ask for help however he tells her that
he cannot pick her up because he's on a
trip at that moment amber confesses that
she has lied to him and that she is not
from the united states but from mexico
therefore she does not have an id and
cannot call the police
the uncle seems disappointed but still
tells her that he will help her but she
needs to stay out of trouble for now
amber goes to ask the owner for the
money he owed and he is not in his room
so she decides to leave without the
money
she goes to various places but they do
not let her in because she does not have
enough money
then we see she's on a train when
suddenly she sees a box with monster
hands coming out amber then wakes up
from the nightmare and realizes she's in
the cafeteria with her suitcases at that
moment the owner appears and amber asks
him for the money however the owner
tells her that the money is in the house
amber although not wanting to return to
the house after what she saw
accepts this because she needs the money
they arrive at the house and the owner
tells her that her money is in her room
so she goes up to get it
she looks for it everywhere but can't
find it the owner appears and tries to
invite her for a drink but amber only
wants the money the owner tells her that
he wished she hadn't called him because
he didn't want to hurt her amber gets
scared and tries to leave but the man
stops her saying that her brother asked
him not to let her go at that moment the
brother shows up and approaches the
woman he takes the bottle of wine and
makes amber take a big drink and then
they laugh at her
the owner tells amber to try not to
escape again or he will do worse things
to her both brothers leave amber locks
herself in her room and then after a few
minutes two girls who will also live
there ask to enter
amber lets them in and they tell her
that they are not allowed to leave
either the women tell amber that they
also hear voices and see ghosts and
dream about a monster coming out of a
box
then at night amber sees several ghosts
in her room staring at her however the
ghosts disappear and another ghost shows
up which seems to be her mother's
this one says her name and at that
moment she wakes up since it was only a
nightmare when she wakes up she realizes
that the brothers are taking the two
women so she tries to help them but
doesn't succeed and they end up blocking
her in the room
at that moment someone rings a doorbell
of the house so the owner has to open it
we see that it's amber's uncle who asks
about her but the owner tells him that
she doesn't live there
amber manages to break a window and yell
at her uncle to help her when he finds
out he pushes the owner and runs to look
for her however when he reaches a room
he's caught by the owner's brother who
beats him up and kills him then the
brothers tie amber and carry her
upstairs with the other two women the
owner's brother takes one of these women
to the basement while the owner stays to
smear amber with a strange dust the
owner tells amber that what they're
doing is a ritual and they only need a
few more women to finish it and that
everything is part of his brother's plan
he's only supporting him amber asked the
owner to let her go and to escape
together since apparently the owner
doesn't agree with what his brother is
doing
but he doesn't agree to run away with
her at that moment the brother shows up
with the wound on his hand he tells
amber that the other girl fought and
scratched him but his womb suddenly
heals then the owner's brother carries
amber to the basement
and she sees several ghosts along the
way at the basement the brother ties her
on the table and then goes to open a
stone box the same box amber had seen in
her nightmares and leaves her alone
amber tries to get away because she
knows that nothing good will come out of
that box
and at that moment some butterflies
appear which make amber unconscious
amber then begins to dream that she is
with her mother in the hospital and she
has to stay with her while a gigantic
monster is coming out of the box the
monster approaches amber with the
intention of eating her while amber
continues to dream about her mother at
that moment amber tells her mother that
she is not going to stay any longer but
her mother takes her by the neck and
demands her to stay and we see her dream
is being manipulated by the monster
amber then decides to kill her mother in
the dream so that she lets her go
and when she wakes up she realizes that
she is no longer tied to the table and
she sees that the monster has just
returned to the box amber looks inside
the box and finds a small corpse so she
decides to close it again
then as she's about to leave the
basement she decides to seek revenge
against the brothers and takes a weapon
she goes to the room where the brothers
are and attacks the owner leaving him on
the ground
then she goes against the brother but he
manages to defend himself and take the
weapon away the brother twists amber's
ankle and fights against another girl
who just escaped amber tries to take the
weapon again but at that moment the
brother returns and fights with her
however amber manages to wound him in
the neck with a small knife
then amber takes the weapon and kills
the brother but she realizes that the
owner is still alive so she decides to
take him as a sacrifice to the monster
in the basement
when amber is about to leave the house
she suddenly sees that the owner has
become one of the ghosts
then she feels how her ankle heals
itself and sees several butterflies
appear from the basement so she smiles
the end if you liked this video please
leave a like and subscribe to continue
receiving the recaps of the best horror
movies my name is tc and i'll see you in
the next one goodbye